indeed it was so you listen to Steve
Kerr explain that and and looking at he
says Rudy goar yeah I was surprised I
was surprised he wasn't and that's why
Draymond I like to see the play though
well we have video of I mean I mean I'm
know I'm talking about like I we never
even looked for the rooted part no I did
you didn't look the part where he was
touching uh okay keep your keep your
eyes on Rudy goar right now here he goes
in he just holding him you can't see
Draymond just holding no he's choking
him the other angle so right here so
here comes Rudy yep he choking he's just
holding CL he CH he don't even have
around the neck stop his neck he don't
have Tap Out Rudy Tap Out Rudy
MMA there you go you got to tap out you
got to tap
out oh my God I I I disagree with you
see look at you look at you stop it you
did the same thing no no I did grabbing
him Chuck I tell you talking about can
we see the whole play let me see the you
can't learn anything from that yeah
anyway um y' don't have that upstairs
you got to go to the Internet just so
you so you think Rudy should have gotten
TOS too I mean they all part of it if
you're going to put it like this if Klay
Thompson gets tossed it's the same thing
well they started the thing I no if Klay
Thompson got tossed Rudy go was for the
game I'm not saying suspension just
looking at it right there Rudy Rudy
anybody invol Rudy didn't have him round
the neck either he had him around the
around the waist
area he had arm he had an arm up there
around wasn't like this but his arm was
okay well don't compare what Draymond
did I'm not comparing no I'm just saying
if one gets ejected now look now look
arm is not
around right there he let it go
immediately he let it go immediately he
let it go immediately had to let it go
immediately cuz there was a man choking
him now drar to for sure that's
100% what ises Draymond do it says ch%
good job
Draymond let's let's move
on